- Il est probablement
le résident le plus marquant
de l'histoire d'Ahuntsic.
Le souvenir de Maurice Richard,
légende du hockey,
est d'ailleurs encore bien
vivant dans le quartier.
Et depuis cinq ans, c'est même
la circonscription qui porte
son nom.
- C'est Audrey Murray,
je suis votre candidate pour
la Coalition avenir Québec dans
le comté de Maurice-Richard.
- La CAQ, qui avait terminé
troisième en 2018, a, cette
fois, bon espoir de l'emporter,
et mise sur l'avocate
Audrey Murray.
AUDREY MURRAY, candidate, CAQ
Maurice-Richard
- C'est très favorable. Je pense
que les gens reconnaissent aussi
mon profil. Les gens sont
studieux, ont regardé
ce que j'avais fait dans la vie
auparavant. Alors je pense
que le vent est du bon côté
pour nous cette fois-ci.
- C'est moi qui me présente ici
pour être votre prochain député
avec Québec solidaire.
- Haroun Bouazzi, un travailleur
du monde de la finance,
représente les solidaires,
qui avaient perdu par à peine
500 voix la dernière fois.
HAROUN BOUAZZI, candidat, QS
Maurice-Richard
- On a dépassé le demi-millier
de bénévoles juste ici,
dans Maurice-Richard.
Donc on est très confiants,
nos solutions répondent
aux problèmes de la population
en matière d'éducation,
d'accès à la santé, de lonté, d.
- Bonjour! Je m'appelle Jonathan
Marleau, je suis le candidat
pour Maurice-Richard.
- Le candidat libéral, directeur
dans une banque, tente aussi
de succéder à Marie Montpetit,
qui avait été élue sous
la bannière de son parti.
Elle avait ensuite été expulsée
du caucus, en raison
d'allégations de harcèlement
psychologique.
JONATHAN MARLEAU, candidat, PLQ
Maurice-Richard
- Les gens sont reconnaissants
de son passage en politique.
Maintenant, c'est sûr que moi,br
vers l'avenir aussi.
Donc quand on va présenter
aux gens, c'est surtout...
les discussions sont surtout
orientées sur qu'est-ce qui
se passe après le 3 octobre.
- J'ai un peu mon idée, mais
on peut encore me convaincre.
- S'il reste encore des
indécis...
- Je suis pas encore sûr.
Je pense Québec solidaire.
- Vous hésitez entre quels
partis?
- Les libéraux et la CAQ.
- La plupart des électeurs
rencontrés avaient déjà fait
leur choix.
- Le Parti québécois.
- Pourquoi?
- J'ai toujours voté
pour le Parti québécois.
- Monsieur Legault.
- Pourquoi?
- Je pense que c'est un homme
qui sait où il s'en va.
- Je suis Québec solidaire.
- Pourquoi?
- Je trouve que ça représente
pas mal notre génération
des jeunes.
- Le Parti vert.
- J'ai confiance en lui.
- En Monsieur Legault?
- Moi, je suis péquiste depuis,
depuis que c'est commencé.
- Moi, c'est Québec solidaire.
- Pourquoi?
- Parce que j'ai entendu dire
que c'est les genre...
C'est eux qui s'intéressaient
le plus à l'environnement.
- Chaque vote pour nous
va faire une grande différence.
- C'est une vraie course. Alors,
on est sur le terrain à tous les
jours.
- Chaque parti profite
maintenant du dernier sprint
pour faire le plein d'appuis,
mais tous se voient déjà sur
la plus haute marche du podium.
- Votre niveau de confiance
de 0 à 10 en vue de lundi?
- Je vais le mettre à 9.
- Mon niveau de confiance
est à 10.
- Je dirais 9,5. Oui, un bon
9,5. Parce qu'il faut se garder
une gêne.
- Dans une circonscription qui a
l'habitude des changements
de couleurs, la rondelle
est maintenant dans le camp
des électeurs.
Ici Mathieu Papillon,
Radio-Canada, Mon